[موسيقى]
نحن الان في مقاطعه يورتشر شمالي انجلترا
حتى نلتقي برزان الصوص صاحبه معمل داما
الذي ينتج جبنه حلوم في مقاطعه انجليزيه
بامتياز عاده ما تتنافس فيها عشرات اصناف
الجبنه التي تعرف بها بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
من صخب مدينه دمشق العتيقه واسواقها
الشعبيه العابقه بروائح البهارات والتاريخ
الى سكون ريف انجلترا ومزارعه الجميله
انتقلت رزان الصوص وتغيرت حياتها وصلت
بريطانيا لاجئه في عام 2012 ورغم انها
تحمل شهاده في الصيدله لم تستطع اختراق
سوق العمل رزان ابنه المدينه لم تجد صعوبه
في الاختلاط بسكان بلده طبعها قروي فوجدت
في حليب الابقار فرصه لحياه جديده وعمل
مربح وحملت نفسها الدمشقيه للريف
الانجليزي
طيب عندهم حليب جيد ليش ما نعمل حلومه نحن
انا اللي فكرت في طيب انا
وحليب البقر يعني اكثر ب 80% من حليب
الغنم ولا الخروف فقلت انه اوكي شو الفرق
قعدت ادرس واعمل بحث هون بلشت بصراحه
البوادر الفكره
يوكير دامت تشيز هي اسم الشركه تبعنا ونحن
بالبدايه لما بلشنا
نفكر انه بدنا نعمل بدي اعمل جبنه صرنا شو
بدنا نسمي الشركه فحبيت انه خلي الشيء
يرمز لاصلي فيوكشر هي لانه المكان الجديد
اللي نحنا صار بيتنا وداما هي مثل اختصار
لدى
دمشق عشان انا بهذاك الوقت قلت بركي نجحنا
ما ننسى وين نحنا جذورنا من وين نحنا
قصرنا
وكان النجاح من نصيبها معمل داما ينتجون
نحو 800 قالب من الجبنه في اليوم حاصدا
عشرات الجوائز في مسابقات اجبان محليه
وعالميه تنهال الطلبيات بلا توقف
فالمنتجات لم تعجب سكان فقط بل ذاع صيتها
بين افراد العائله الملكيه
الاميره ان زارت بنفسها معمل داما لتذوق
جبنه باتت تعرف باحدث اضافه الى عائله
الاجبان في
[موسيقى]
اول شيء انا ما بعرف كيف بتصير الجبنه ولا
بحياتي ساويت اي قالب جبنه قبل ولا حتى
فكرت فيها لانه موجوده ببلادنا وبوفرها
فانا بهذاك الوقت صرت احس انه عندي شعور
مسؤوليه انه انا لازم ساوي خطوه لازم اعمل
شي مشان عيلتي يعني ما معقول نقعد ونمطر
ببريطانيا في نظام اسمه سيستم اسمه او هو
مساعدات الدوله بتساعد يعني بالحياه
اقل مستوى معيشه بحيث انه الانسان بيقدر
يامن اكله وشربه مسكن
يعني بس هذا الشيء كان صعب عليه كثير صعب
لانه انا بالنسبه لالي بحس انه الله
اعطانا القوه والعقل ونحن عنا امتحان نحنا
هلا واجهنا صعوبه يعني نحن لازم ما نستسلم
لازم نحن نتعب ونشتغل انا بالنسبه لالي
اني اكل من تعبي ولو اقل احسن لين ما اكون
عم بطلب مساعدات
[موسيقى]
انا بلشت بمحل تيك اوي كان شوب بابو يعني
انا بصراحه احيانا بقعد
وبطلع انه شو هاد اللي صار معي انا وين
هذاك كان حلم وهلا علم ولا العكس
سردت الانتصارات بس انا كتير تعذبت وكثير
قدرت قلت بالقليل
ولما نحنا قررنا نشتغل يعني في اشياء كتير
فيزيكلي انا ساويت انا ما بحياتي كنت
متوقعه اني انا اتعب هالاجساوي
تاتي المخاوف وعلى حجم الاحلام احيانا
وبين الخوف من حرب التهمت الحجره والبشر
والخوف من تحديات المجهول اختارت رزان
الصوص ان تمتطي احلامها وتكون سوريه يفخر
اي بلد بوائها
[موسيقى]
تغربوا عن بلدانهم لكنهم تميزوا واتقنوا
الاندماج في المجتمعات التي وصلوا اليها
فقصه رزان ما هي الا مثال يروي جزءا ولو
بسيطا من رحله مستمره يخوضها السوريون هنا
وفي العالم فجبنا الدام هذه في طريقها
لتصبح علامه تجاريه بين اشهر صناع الجبنه
في بريطانيا لصباح العربيه من لندن عرب
عبد الحق
[موسيقى]